محي مصطفى سيزرع قمح هذا العام ليكرر
تجربه العام الماضي نظرا لانه يعرف مسبقا
السعر الذي سيبيع به فقد رفعت الحكومه سعر
شراء القمح المحلي في محاوله لتجنب الوقوع
في ازمه توريد للقمح بسبب التطورات
العالميه ورغم رفع السعر الا ان شكاوى
المزارعين لم تتوقف عاليه جدا
من خمس شكاير لوليا يعني كنت حضرتك احب زي
ما بيجيبوا من بره ياخدوا مني حضرتك
مثل محصول القمح من الزراعه حتى حصل عندما
هو حطك يعني حتى لو تلاحظ انه في مزارع
على مستوى جمهوريه كان العالم السابق بس
اشغل ده للفدان انما الحقول الارشاديه
انموذجيه كالمتصطادها على مستوى جمهوريه
كان 25 ارض الفدان بدات زراعه القمح في
نوفمبر الماضي في مصر واقبل عليها
المزارعون بعد ما حسبوا حساباتهم كالمعتاد
فوجدوها مناسبه عند السعر المعلن وقتها
واليوم وبعد تحرير سعر الصرف جاءت الزياده
في سعر التوريد للصوامع الحكوميه كحافزا
اضافيه
بالحشرات اللي موجوده فيها تامر العربيه
محافظه القليوبيه